[Music]
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Forbes
reporting Americans are overdue with
their car payments at the highest rate
in nearly 30 years higher car prices and
Rising interest rates are hindering car
owners ability to afford their vehicle
payments as 6.1% of subprime Auto
borrowers are at least 60 days past due
on their loans the highest percentage in
data backing all dating back all the way
to
1994 ACC according to Bloomberg gen Z
and Millennials May account for a
significant amount of the borrowers
behind on their auto loans as the two
generations recorded auto loan
delinquency rates last year that were
significantly higher than prepandemic
levels according to NBC News interest
rates for used cars are 132 on average
for those with Fair Credit but can rock
it up to 21 with those with worse
Credit in subprime loans
6.1% behind on a subprime loan yeah they
shouldn't have buy been buying these
cars to begin with that's the problem
yeah it's that's the problem when it's
subprime it's
because you got low credit you've got
low income there's a reason that they
don't want you borrowing money and so
they say well we'll just jack up the
interest rate right so that we can cover
our butts highrisk borrower yep so
they're going to charge you super high
interest rates and and continue your
problems for you because they know but I
was forced to buy a car no you weren't
they did not have a gun you were not
forced to do anything I have chosen to
do some stupid things in my life but I
have to take ownership of the fact that
I chose to do it I was not forced to do
it I wanted it I had car fever I led the
smell of the leather
mhm and I paid way too much and I put it
on a high interest rate cuz I was stupid
yeah and um I suspect that some people
have done that well what's interesting
is it's this is significantly higher
than pre-pandemic
levels which to me indicates that after
their pandemic people got used to extra
money coming in whether it was subsidies
from the government or whether it was I
wasn't paying my student loan and let's
just go get a car let's get a new let's
get a Camry we have the illusion of
margin in our budget because of these
Biden bucks that's right and uh there's
not a real margin in my budget but I
will go and act like there is and cu the
famous famous words of right before you
die we can afford the payments these are
the famous words of fools right before
you prove you're a fool right because
all you all you care about is how much
per month rich people ask how much poor
people ask how much down how much a
month
yeah yeah yeah and they're not talking
about what these payments are because we
know what the average payment
is $77 last time I
checked yeah yeah so um
$600 650 the interesting thing though
the way Forbes and the uh Financial
media couches these things it say if the
people that did this are victims right
you know it's like um the Gen Z and
Millennial Millennials May account for a
significant amount of the borrowers
behind on their loans these two
generations have recorded auto loan
delinquency rates last year that were
significantly higher than prepandemic
levels no I I I can't get behind that
Dave because they went to the dealership
and they said sign me up sign I'll sign
on the dotted line they they made that
choice no one said you had to get a car
loan no one said you had to spend
$25,000 on a brand new car you chose to
do that higher vehicle prices are at
fault higher borrowing cost costs are
called according to the article no um
let me help you you don't want to know
what causes vehicle prices to come down
lower
demand uh people aren't buying them
they'll price adjust that's what's
happening in higher education right now
colleges are getting ready to experience
this uh people have decided it's I'm not
going to pay $250,000 for degree in
left-handed puppetry it doesn't make
sense and end up being a barista no I
don't I'm not going to do that and um
people are waking up and you know what
if car prices are so high then don't buy
them that that's what I'm saying oh
shocking look when see here's the thing
it's that it's the ancient word we have
forgotten the ancient word no yeah you
press your tongue towards the roof of
your mouth release and blow air P it
sounds like this
no no you can't tell anyone no because
immediately you're that's hate speech
now yeah no and you told me I can't do
something I just did that's right no
yeah I don't like the Ramy I didn't you
know I wasn't running a poll I'm just
here to help you but Dave I have to live
in my truth and my truth is telling me
that I need self-care and I need a new
car and the way for me to take care of
myself is to get this new car the
problem you have your own truth and I
have my own truth and they're in
Conflict one of them is not the truth
hm so it's kind you're not allowed to
like own your own truth it's sorry it's
not like a thing you can buy you can't
go to Walmart and buy a box of Truth and
it's different than you know it's a
variety I get a variety pack a different
kind of Truth depending on what truth I
want now one truth if it's in conflict
with another Truth by definition one of
them is not the truth the truth is
independent of your little feelings
darling I'm I'm offended Dave I know I'm
offended and I'm supposed to
care I love it oh it's so fun hey guys
if you can't tell we're making fun of
you yes we are definitely um yeah you're
if you make all of your adult decisions
with your feelings you are by definition
a
child and so when you purchase something
that you can't afford with money that
you don't have to impress people you
don't even really like at 21% on
subprime and then you get delinquent on
the payment yeah
$1,142 car payment
then you become a statistic and then
people like Forbes make fun of your
entire
generation because of that and by the
way the genz and the Millennials are
actually two very good Financial
Generations they've done a very good job
by and large but a portion of every
generation is stupid well the problem is
and a portion of the Gen Z and a portion
of the Millennials a portion of the
boomers are stupid the problem is Dave
is if you're always pointing to the the
problem out there that's the reason it's
the the the dealership it's the interest
rates it's inflation it's supply chain
if you're always pointing to something
out there for your own behavior you'll
never be able to fix it you'll never be
able to fix it and you'll never get out
of debt and you'll never stop fooling
around with cars and everybody has to
take that moment and look inward when
Sam and I were getting out of debt we
had one a Jeep car payment for 303 and a
Hummer H3 for 432 a month that's so much
in car payments and I I mean I thought
like this is the way you're supposed to
live life this what you have to do and
it took me listening to the ramsy show
and listening to things and people going
that's so dumb that's so stupid and at
some point you have to look at yourself
and go could could I really be making a
stupid decision and not blame you're
never going to get past it you've got to
look there's a reason you don't have any
money and it's sitting in your
driveway it's the largest thing we all
buy that goes down in value I don't hate
cars I just hate what they do to people
that can't afford them right and um you
know when you start talking I mean if
you take $550 a month and invest it from
age 30 to age 65 you're going to have
5.5 million doll in a mutual fund hope
you like the car